hey David do you talk a lot about
reading should it be embarrassing not to
read regularly no it shouldn't be
embarrassing because I don't know if
embarrassing or shaming people that
don't read is the best way to get people
to read but I think from an early age it
can become sort of stigmatized to be a
bookworm or to be someone who likes to
read and that's a problem because
reading habits are often determined
pretty early on in life both when it
comes to parents reading to their kids
but also the reaction that kids get in
school when they carry around a book
that you don't have to be reading that
book and you're still reading a book
what that when kids mate get made fun of
for that you're stigmatizing reading in
a way so I don't think it should be
embarrassing not to read but it should
be a completely encouraged activity at
all levels of society a lot of this is
formed during school years and the
problem is that education has become
political in the United States we know
that all else being equal now I'll give
you exceptions in a second but all else
being equal more education leads to
people being more to the left reading
more about the world in an honest way
and I don't mean reading those pop
nonfiction bestsellers like Tucker
Carlson and Ann Coulter and Laura
Ingraham stuff but really reading about
the world reading about behavioral
economics and history and philosophy and
even even reading a diverse selection of
fiction books that is going to have a
liberalizing effect on the world
population and so we've already seen
that the right is sort of planting
planting their feet drawing drawing a
line in the sand on the issue of
Education we had that famous clip from
Rick Santorum from years ago about we
are never going to have the intelligent
people the educated they're just never
going to be on our side and it's not
because of an in doctrine re sort of
circumstance it's because the more you
learn about the world around you the
more educated you are the more
well-rounded you are in terms of your
knowledge of the world now and as it
used to be you are more likely to move
to the
left so that is also a problem and that
doesn't relate so much to reading
specifically but reading as sort of a
characteristic of having a worldview
that is better formed and so we are
fighting not only stigma about nerdy
reading activities but we're also
fighting the way that the right has
successfully stigmatized education and
we've got to fight both and people
should be reading more and I will
continue to make every effort to show
you that by reading you become a more
informed human who exists in the world
and it's a good thing and I'll keep
recommending books to you that I'm
reading